[Music]
this is a medical image of a brain tumor
most cancer patients undergoing brain
surgery don't even know what kind of
tumor they have
because getting a diagnosis can take a
while a doctor has to take a tissue
sample
and send it to a lab where it's then
examined
prepared as a slide and interpreted by a
specialist to get a diagnosis
but now artificial intelligence is
rapidly speeding up this process
using millions of medical images
researchers have trained an algorithm to
predict an accurate cancer diagnosis
within minutes not only can this improve
the speed and accuracy of surgery
but it can streamline the traditional
workflow for getting a diagnosis
especially for hospitals that don't have
easy access to a lab
this is just one example of how people
are using artificial intelligence today
ai has expanded well beyond the field of
computer science
into many other parts of society so what
else are we using it for
how have we integrated ai into our
personal
and professional lives
[Music]
ai research has come a long way we're at
the point now where systems can even do
some things better than humans
we're using ai and everything from
hiring practices
to online banking to how we choose music
ai has a lot of presence in people's
lives it's in
a lot of the devices that we use every
single day when you
use your smartphone for instance these
are all examples of ai applications
when i use google maps google maps uses
ai and
when i use youtube youtube makes
recommendations it's the way
that siri can listen to your voice and
search the internet for what you're
looking for
recommending movies if you use netflix
or recommending
products if you use amazon
but for an algorithm to function really
well its task has to be specific
and very well defined that's the tricky
part
people kind of expect ai to be perfect
all the time or to not really make
mistakes
again this kind of goes back to a more
traditional view of what ai was like
something that acted
or thought kind of like a human thinks
and acts that's not really the case at
all
let's just take one of the examples that
you know
we're all very familiar with right now
which is
digital assistance so you come home and
you say alexa play some
christmas music it will pull up
something based upon
some basic training that it's had to
associate certain words with certain
content
but the other day when i was at my
friend's house and
he said you know alexa please put on
some fun music and it was totally
confused i didn't even know what to do
with that because it's expecting a genre
right
the instant you do something kind of
weird or not what it's
been trained on it completely falls
apart it doesn't even come close to
providing you with what you want
okay so ai may still be flawed but it's
really useful
it can help us process and analyze huge
amounts of data
which is why we've come to rely on it in
everyday life
it has the potential to transform every
industry
one of the biggest examples is
healthcare
i focus on machine learning for health i
try to train machine learning algorithms
to
do what a clinician might have done or
inform a clinician about what processes
might be better for them
maybe a doctor wants to know every six
hours whether a patient might need an
intervention
if we can give them that information
with high accuracy it can help them plan
which patients they can focus on
we're also using ai in other areas like
immigration
people have started to look at
artificial intelligence as a means of
analyzing these big mountains of data
to help people for example with refugee
claims
if you know we don't have the human
capacity to go through all of this data
but maybe ai can quickly find these are
the people who are most at risk or
in need we should think of ai as a tool
it does come with some challenges but
it's a powerful technology
that has immense potential to improve
human life
as we look towards the future we just
have to make sure that we're using it in
a way that benefits
all of us if people aren't informed and
are worried about these hypothetical
situations it can
distract or devolve the conversation for
instance killer robots
aren't going to show up tomorrow but
bias and privacy are
very important issues that are affecting
people today it's like a paintbrush
we could paint some really ugly things
but we could also paint really beautiful
things
and it's up to us as a society to decide
that these tools machine learning and
artificial intelligence
are tools that we want to use for public
good and we're going to enable them to
do that
and regulate them to do only that
[Music]